the Joe Rogan experience you have a
drink for you on stage I don't drink
alcohol at all no no what about weed I
won't do anyway you know drug nothing I
grew up in I think I just don't I mean I
hate it
alcohol does nothing for me it makes me
sleepy and um my mom was an alcoholic
and ice always say I'm gonna be nothing
like this [ __ ] mission accomplished
yeah I don't I don't do it my whole
family drink and I just don't do it no I
don't I don't smoke weed I don't you
know I was just telling them earlier
like junebug tried to smoke weed one
time and it with his white friends but
they were so stupid Joe they didn't know
how to roll the weed
so they got that they got the UH to copy
your paper off the machine and roll the
reading there yeah and Tommy leading it
just burnt and all the wheat fell in his
chest and I beat the dog [ __ ] out of
junebug and for you to create an
appetite you already [ __ ] fat oh my
god and I just told my kids when I was
young guys say look I told my son I kill
I said look I get food stamps and I
don't get enough food stand for your
weed habit so we're not gonna do drugs
we're not gonna join gangs we're not
gonna do drugs it's awesome [ __ ]
so we're not gonna do it so but junebug
is the only kid I have ahead that really
tried to dab into weed that's a weird
way to do it though copy paper what it's
terrible for you they will go to the
ghetto and by the we out of it other
where I live it they will go over to the
ghetto
Jim look how much how much wheat you buy
1.5 grams what the hell is that I don't
know and I called the police on what do
you I did I called the police on the
shake him up right and I you know my the
police huh yeah but I say hey we blacks
only your guns in the car so come over
here and shake my son on it Napoli's get
over there the police and junebug son go
to school together
this [ __ ] come on and start
crying we love you Jimbo I thought he'd
call you mother [ __ ] cry no I was
crying so that didn't help
but eventually I think he don't stop
smoking now he's gonna stop or start I
think he stopped
I just ran off all his friends I told it
I said look you up your white son just
lost his only black for
I'm a [ __ ] white baby I'm running
back over here with we do more like
everybody at my school say you're just a
[ __ ] my whip them white boys ass cuz I
call I call I called out of prayers I
said they'll be smoking weed and looking
at some little white girl [ __ ] on the
foam I said juma you bless you mama
start in it but his white [ __ ] floating
on he phones oh like a girl from the
school yeah you made trouble for that so
I put put up a chromecast the pitcher
pitches away from Julie Julie and Tim
gravy look dick it's real real small
trying to kill my baby trying to get my
baby locked up in white [ __ ] oh you
don't [ __ ] with white [ __ ] you ain't
gonna be key ain't got enough sense oh
my god so so you had the parents come
over and you had it on the television
what the [ __ ] did they say I can't
believe you did this
what the [ __ ] you mean it was on the
phone they wouldn't speak to me at no no
I don't need no friends oh my god
I said don't you ever in your life
violate no good she gave to one of the
football play he just passed it around
every worse yeah not so nice to junebug
think about he was just so so Gary honor
he's like mom guarantee ain't getting
naked lady can nobody see nothing yeah
[Laughter]
that is the stuff I went to he's the
only one that ever really try me cuz my
other kids you know I tell like I tell
my crack baby I say look I'm gonna take
you out in public but you got an option
do you want the ghetto mom or do you
want the soccer mom and they don't like
to get her mom cuz ghetto mama would
knock the [ __ ] out of him in public
and I give him my option and we get in
public and why people always coming to
me like oh my god your kids are so well
disciplined I said I told him I was
gonna [ __ ] em up what I think you should
[ __ ] your kids up to
tell them I said oh I will [ __ ] you up
don't play with me I feed you when we
was coming back from the Disney Cruise
they was all playing with those little
things that separate you know when
you're in line so I told him like three
full time stop isn't my grandbaby and it
was the full Craig baby so they wouldn't
stop Joe I slept all I'm at the same
time what the [ __ ] what you lookin at me
for you won't saw him to ask him to stop
by full time don't play with me you know
Meniere's bad I've been shot a couple of
time y'all my [ __ ] know I'm crazy and
I just tell them that they get kids the
good kids now oh they know I [ __ ] love
I have a lot of bits about because like
the district like I do this bit about I
used to do this bit about the teachers
school calling me all the time white
schools call you for anything and
anything Joe I mean just dumb [ __ ] black
school we tell them look [ __ ] that shot
at 2:30 don't you wake me up so one of
the big one of the beast I used ter they
call me by my knee in London because she
was sitting at the crayon table with a
little white friends and they're talking
about their daddies so your London say
well the next time I see my daddy I'm
gonna stab him in the neck and all the
white kids started crying and they asked
me to come up there an emergency to come
up there to talk to them I get up them
like ma'am she can't step on that any
knee then they get in jail somebody else
gonna stab a man and knee don't wake me
up from the don't wake me up for this
[ __ ] so they don't know how to
anything I had to set the school down I
said look these kids are from the hood
they only talk and do what they know you
got to give me time to help him grow but
then they wanted to put him on
medication I said what we heard yeah
because they didn't know how to deal
with that they saw so much like a mama
was into horn and Adam Jones the dead
old beating on the mom and I didn't know
how to handle him and I say look we're
gonna help them grow together I said
well what we're not gonna do we're not
gonna put these kids on medication what
we're gonna do is surround them with
love they so good now out of five years
this baby just now passing the ISTEP
test it took a minute to get there but
he's finally there what's up those pump
those standardized tests they give kids
and the kids just wasn't ready right he
not to him in his neighborhood to me
environment and he wasn't used to
anything you know they talk telling you
see our country I am what they talk
straight
three so come sometime what the [ __ ] are
y'all talking about we bout it bout it
another [ __ ] you ain't get a setup far
bus you cross your head without a body
yeah they ready to rumble they ready to
fight but little boy I'm bout about I
said put your [ __ ] finger now if I
break it